so at the end of our podcast what we do
is we do a thing called unhelpful advice
right so we have people email us and um
they ask us questions and we try to
answer them for them they don't it
doesn't have to be helpful yeah well it
shouldn't be right we're not it can be
some okay they're suicidal yeah yes look
curveball right oh yeah I'd like sat up
straight on hopeful vice with Bobby
kalila Rory Scovel which like a serious
one or a lighter one serious first my
question is about your creative process
and dealing with rejection I'm a fiction
writer that has yet to be published in a
real fiction magazine I'm also an addict
back in college for a couple of years I
wrote stories frequently productively
that were generally well received which
turned out to bolster my confidence and
creativity two years after graduation
when I started receiving rejection after
rejection after rejection by publishers
I began to lose confidence and became
hyper critical at my work like you Bobby
I've always overanalyze situations and
crucify myself internally I've reached
the point where I can't even write a
paragraph without a voice in the back of
my head criticizing every word I know
that opiates are demons and they aren't
making me better as a writer whatsoever
yet I don't know how to regain my
swagger and write about without over
analyzing my work my question is as an
artist who is also is also far too
critical of your own work and I had and
an addict how do you shut up the
thoughts and doubt in your head oh my
god it's like you talking about the
meditation answered this question
chicken or the egg that's what just
happened right now my honest answer is
just you can't live in the results
number one you know a lot of times I do
things and I go what is it gonna get me
and why isn't this not happening I mean
it's a second hundred percent do the
[ __ ] work exactly we said earlier
about the bands like The Velvet
Underground making music because that's
what they wanted to make yes not because
they were looking for an endgame yeah
yeah The Velvet Underground's first
album the the banana one with the Andy
Warhol one sold 500 copies and but
there's a legend in a rumor
that the 500 copies that they sold
everyone that bought that album started
a band yeah right so they didn't have
financial success based on it now it
obviously over the years has made money
but um you know that album influenced a
lot of people but you know in the
beginning New York back then back in the
factory day they probably didn't like
even no one probably even mentioned it
right I'll be thought it was like a
failure maybe sure you know so it's like
for me it's like you know you you know
when we worry and I first started doing
stand-up we got we were bail runs we're
besties man we were absolute besties and
then Bobby goes promise me this for a
super long time we'll pretend like we
don't and then I'll have you on my
podcast and I go what is a podcast
because even I don't know doing it it's
like you didn't you know you would sign
up you sometimes you would go late no
audience yeah right and you did that
night after night and you never I
honestly swear to god back then I would
do shows and think to myself I'm
probably never gonna make it there's I
can't force I don't know how to get an 8
I don't know anything about it you know
I mean I'm just there's no one in the
audience they're giving me three minutes
I'm how but you know what you I did it
because by performing it gave me like a
little an adrenalin rush yeah and it
also was the first thing where I did
that I did that was brave yeah because I
was such a coward growing up and just
kind of scared and shy and it was and I
was proud of myself that every night I
could just go up there and make a fool
of myself and that alone I could have
just done that for the rest of my life
but fortunately I created a career off
of it you know right but but I to sort
of like go off of that answer that that
early that that first like three years
is probably the best it ever is and you
don't know it you don't know it at the
time how good it is but you're beat but
also it's because you're not clouded by
fame or fortune because no part of you
has any concept that that
ever happen and not that that you wanted
to happen but you don't even think that
that's like a thing you just are like oh
I discovered the sort of underground
world of comics going onstage in these
places but also it probably felt so good
because ultimately that was probably
your first introduction of who you are
and ultimately will become whereas you
were like perceiving yourself to be this
person then you did this thing and it
was almost like you were saying it out
there I am that's what I do this is what
I do you do literally almost I almost am
Jada it right now man yeah how you got
good at like if that wasn't who you were
and what just your thing you wouldn't be
sitting here you would have gotten this
far you know I think I think we both
know that you you can't really in stand
up I don't think you can really fake it
you know what I mean like there are
people were like oh that person steals
jokes most comics are like well I hope
they don't steal my jokes but you're not
gonna get very far doing that like it's
there was a time when you were offended
you want to kill them why then there was
a time when you were like oh you just
you will either learn to not I mean that
your first time going said you need a
joke yo joke and think how quickly you
were like oh that wasn't the right thing
I gotta clean yeah but there's some
people who go well no it's working so
I'll just keep doing it and you go oh
you don't even understand what the pure
thing of it is because you're not
supposed to be doing this no not for you
it's like in the beginning I thought
that jokes was gonna it's not the jokes
I know beat me being authentically
myself to you yeah well what is paying
for the jokes exactly don't care about
the jokes I can i I can really relate to
this person because I think that not
being an addict but somebody who has had
a lot of like abuse in my life abuse
turns into perfectionism so for me I had
to reframe the idea of rejection or
abuse and not take it as not render me
paralyzed basically so if there's a way
for you to sort of reframe that
rejection and not really see it as a
rejection rather than like okay this is
just all part of the process
because what happens with me is that I
never fully follow through with a lot of
things in my life because you know I was
beat constantly by my mom for the
tiniest thing for the tiniest error hmm
and I don't know if that's a part of his
history but when I go to therapy that's
something that I constantly struggle
with is to be able to take a negative
and not feel not have it to feel like an
attack yeah to my being yes it's you
kind of change it so that it lands a
little softer on me so that it feels
like fuel rather than a reason to go
hide in a hole somewhere right yeah yeah
yeah I think that the rejection thing I
don't think there is this world where
that ends mm-hm I don't think it ends I
think you right what's good and and like
you said you're not you can't worry
about the results I think that's a great
point I right now I'm sitting in an
abyss of rejection where I've made this
documentary and I don't know if anyone's
going to buy it and I actually think
it's very good
I've made this TV show that I don't know
if anyone ever see it and I actually
think it's pretty good my first a bit
like doing a TV show I've written this
other thing and all these things are
three plus years two to three years of
like putting these things together and
making them I've written this other
thing that I think would be so fun it's
like a comedy special and no one is
biting on it but saying this is a good
script and I'm so I'm in this point of
going well what is what do I do if I
create stuff like why would I create it
if I can't push it past the next thing
and so I am myself similar and I also
wrote this letter under a pseudonym
because let's suppose publishers did
bite what he's written yes the rejection
doesn't end there you still have you
could be rejected by the public you
could be rejected by critics you could
be rejected the whole way through to the
very end is one giant rejection